Facebook's treatment of diamond and silk
is just the latest example of censoring
conservatives voices the pro-trump
sisters became a hot topic during
Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg second day
of grilling on Capitol Hill today do you
subjectively manipulate your algorithms
to prioritize or censor speech
congresswoman we don't think about what
we're doing a censoring speech I think
there are there are types of content
like terrorism that I think that we all
agree we do not want to have on our
service so we build systems that can
identify those and can remove that
content and we're very proud of that
work let me tell you something right now
I dominant silk is not terrorism thing
let's get reaction for the ladies
themselves joining the angle now the one
and only diamond and silk okay
diamond let's start with you Marsha
Blackburn
jumped on that because Mark Zuckerberg
will worry about terrorism I'm looking
at you too I don't see any terrorism I
don't see any threat to the community
standards or whatever the heck their
justification is I don't see any of it
what did you think about the play that
you guys both got at this hearing and
did you get any satisfaction from what
Mark Zuckerberg said well first of all I
appreciate everyone that really stood up
for us in our platform and even other
conservatives and with Mark Zuckerberg I
was happy to hear him omit that they
made a mistake so now it's time for him
to rectify that mistake
I would like we would like to sit down
and talk directly to Mark Zuckerberg
that's so that he can rectify this here
and make this right well congressman
Barton brought you both up as well let's
play this so people understand what
you're referring to we have the sound
bite please ask mr. Zuckerberg why is
Facebook censoring conservative bloggers
such as Dimond and silk Facebook called
them unsafe to the community that is
ludicrous
they hold concern
views that isn't unsafe what's your
response to congressman in that specific
case our team made an enforcement error
and we have already gotten in touch with
them to reverse it did you get contacted
by Facebook and has this been reversed
no we have not been in communication
with Facebook we have not been contacted
we have not spoken to anyone over the
phone so that was a lie
wait a second this is the second night
we've had you on the second time
Facebook has said they have contacted
you and this has been dealt with and
this is the second night you said no
contact I mean you guys are either not
telling the truth or Facebook and I'm
sorry I trust you guys not Facebook in
this circumstance I mean it is you have
you checked your messages I mean is your
mailbox full like what's going on if you
go to the side of our Facebook page
right now you will see where people are
still having issues with liking and
following our page the same algorithms
are still there nothing has been
resolved no one has been in
communication with Diamond asil all
right they gotta get in touch with you
all right guys there's a headline out
today by this thing called griot here it
is black Trump supporters and Fox News
puppets diamond and silk accused
Facebook of discrimination they call you
Fox News puppets then they say viral
court jesters diamond and silk are
easily president Trump's most vocal
black supporters and have made a name
for themselves dancing for him and his
administration your reaction well you
have to understand that that publication
is just envious publication it's a very
small my new publication that's right
and they're just trying to use us as
clique base because they know nobody
ever read their stuff and they put this
stuff out on Facebook they have hardly
any views so they have to use diamond
and silk name in order for someone to
join read what is joy Reid's role in
that she has some connection to yes for
two years yeah well editor-in-chief
Rosanna calls you comedians and she said
to stop censoring them are you comedians
ladies
I think that we're comedians but what we
say maybe comic or maybe funny cuz but
we really be telling the truth we try
not to be so funny
but it comes down bunny I like it okay
you can have fun ladies you can have fun
and do politics and you do that and I
love it I love it
Facebook get in touch with diamond and
silk ladies thanks so much